Ich habe die Noten von Düsseldorf-Fallen geöffnet.
Ich dachte, wir könnten in die Anzahl der Sitzungen gehen.
Hier gibt es am Anfang Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom.
Ich wollte euch wirklich etwas sagen, was ich mit dem Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom zu tun habe.
Ich vergesse es immer.
Normalerweise sieht es in diesen Noten zwei Akut-Coronavirus-Syndroms.
Einer ist Paul Breitner, der andere Florian Wilms.
Normalerweise gibt es in Düsseldorf vier Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom-Fälle.
Es gibt vier verschiedene Akut-Coronavirus-Syndroms.
Drei von diesen sind Männer und eine Frau.
Die Frau ist ein Taxifahrer.
Die Symptome sind natürlich ähnlich.
Aber nicht in allen Bereichen.
Es gibt verschiedene Symptome.
Paul Breitner hat keine Schittrallanlage.
Er ist nicht in jedem Ort verabschiedet.
Manchmal gibt es auch keine Schittrallanlage.
Es gibt keine Schittrallanlage.
Aber sie sind so ähnlich.
Ich denke, dass es wichtig ist, dass wir es hier sagen.
Wir machen hier nur Paul Breitner und Florian Wilms.
Und dann kommt da eine Frau.
Man denkt, dass es nicht die Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom ist,
weil man das Falle nicht so oft sieht.
Aber normalerweise ist es so.
Es spielen vier verschiedene Fälle.
In den Noten der Person, die im Oktober 2025 ins Kurs in die Saison ist,
gibt es sogar vier verschiedene Akutt-Koronars-Syndrom-Szenen.
Da könnt ihr euch die Anleitung des Fails anschauen.
Wenn ihr etwas zu Akutt-Koronars-Syndrom-Szenen fragen müsst,
dann könnt ihr sie fragen.
Aber was ist das wichtigste an Akutt-Koronars-Syndrom?
Hier werden die Patienten Angst und Angst vor der Todesstörung.
Deswegen ist die empathische Beziehung hier sehr wichtig.
Die Anleitung der Patienten, die EKG, die Vitalparameter, die Leidung,
das zu machen, das zu machen, das zu machen, das zu machen,
dass ihr das wisst, dass ihr das verstanden habt.
Hier sind die anderen nicht so nachhaltig.
Florian Wilms ist hier ein Nachhaltiger.
Weil er viel spricht,
ein paar verschiedene Sachen sagt und fragt.
Da ist auch das Wichtigste, Florian Wilms zu hören.
Zuerst ihn zu entschätzen, zu kümmern.
Dann zu hören, ihm Empathie zu zeigen und an der Sonne zu gehen.
Du musst nicht so viel sagen, du musst nicht so viel erzählen.
Aber zeig dir, dass du Empathie machst.
Darin muss man den Patienten sehr gut hören.
Wenn das so ist, ist Florian Williams nicht problematisch.
Ist es noch etwas anderes, was Sie mit der Akuprogramm-Syndrom fragen möchten?
Die Fragen sind klassisch.
Das kommt mit einer Schmerzmenschung.
Wenn es mit einer Schmerzmenschung kommt, dann bekommst du eine Schmerzmenschung.
In solchen Situationen wird es sehr schmerzhaft.
Das ist eine Schmerzsituation, die sich in einer Schmerzsituation befindet.
So können zwei Schmerzen auf der Klinik festgestellt werden.
Dann wird die Schmerzmenschung auf der Klinik geschlossen.
Wenn du eine Schmerzmenschung hast, dann ist es nicht so, dass du die Schmerzmenschung nicht erfährst.
Wie war deine Schmerzmenschung?
Wie war das, was Sie vorhin gesagt haben?
Wenn Sie das nicht sagen, kann man das fragen.
Dann kann man das fragen.
In der Akutkörner-Syndrom
gibt es etwa das Dichtmersen-Ferster-Linder-Sorgen.
Das ist nicht sehr wichtig, aber Sie können es selbst fragen.
Was ist mit der Arre?
Natürlich, das sind die Fragen, die man zu Beginn fragen kann.
Das sind die grundlegenden Fragen.
In der Akutkörner-Syndrom
gibt es natürlich auch das Dichtmersen-Ferster-Linder-Sorgen.
Man muss sofort fragen, ob man das auch mit anderen Dingen beiträgt.
Haben Sie dabei Lufnod, Engelgefühl, das alles?
Das ist es.
Dann gibt es Leidensie, Untha,
also die Bewerbung von vegetativen Symptomen.
Das ist die Symptom-Aktivierung des Sympathischen Systemes.
Leidensie, Untha, Katzschweiz,
Schwindel,
Müdigkeit, Todesangst,
so wie diese.
Das sind die ganzen Fragen des Akutkörner-Syndroms.
Außerdem, wenn man etwas schreiben will,
wenn man etwas schreiben will,
dann kann man das fragen.
Ja, ein paar Fragen.
Nicht nur ein paar.
Dann gibt es zum Beispiel die Lungenembolie.
Du kannst es so nennen.
Wir haben beide eine Frage gefragt.
Das war's.
Das hat auch mein Chef Abraham bezeichnet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er hier ist.
Die Differential Diagnostics.
Er hat die Antiküste der Akutkörner-Embolie gesagt.
Ich habe die beiden bezeichnet.
Ja, ich habe die beiden bezeichnet.
Ja, Herr.
In Ihren Noten gibt es auch eine Art Dissektion.
Darf ich das nicht bezeichnen?
Nein, das ist nicht nötig.
Ich wollte normalerweise drei Schriften schreiben.
Aber als ich es nachher gemacht habe,
habe ich zwei Differentials bezeichnet.
Weil ich es mir einfacher machen wollte.
Ich habe mich etwas aufgetauscht.
Du hast vorhin etwas gemacht.
Danach hast du die Differential Diagnostics
in die zweite Runde der Out-Disektion gemacht.
Aber wir bleiben in der Lungenembolie.
Wir bleiben in den beiden.
Dann gibt es Gert hier.
In der letzten Zeit,
war Gert ein Frauen-Fall.
Hier war ein Frau von der Zugbegleiterin.
Aber in der letzten Zeit
war Gert ein Mann-Fall.
In der Mann-Fall-Fall war er Polizist.
Das war eine der Erleichter.
Ich habe einen Freund,
der mit mir zusammenarbeitet.
Er ist ein Polizist.
Er soll natürlich kein Frankreich sein.
Er muss nicht ohne這樣的 Anmerkungen außerhalb des dehrens leben.
Er verschämte sich vor einiger Zeit
und ist verletzt.
Er ist in einer Situation, in der er mit dem Schuss geht,
und er wird von seiner Hand getroffen.
Dann wird er in der Operation,
und er kann seine Hände nicht gut benutzen.
Er kann die Waffe nicht gut benutzen.
Dann wird er in einer Rückseite,
in einer Büroarbeit, geübt.
Dann ist er nicht sehr froh,
weil er mit dem Schuss nicht so viel Spaß hat.
Dann beginnt er zu schreien,
und er wird sich nicht gut fühlen.
Er beginnt zu trinken.
Das ist so ein Fall.
Das bedeutet, dass er sich nicht schreit.
Und er spricht von diesen Fällen,
die er in der Operation besucht hat.
Er spricht von diesen Fällen.
Das bedeutet, dass er sich nicht schreit.
Aber normalerweise ist er schreit.
Gestern Abend, vor dem Schuss,
hatte ich eine sehr große Brustschmerzen.
Es dauerte eine Stunde.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Das passiert oft.
Es kann euch ein bisschen schreien,
dass es ein Schuss ist.
So ist es.
Was ist das, was du für eine besondere Frage haben willst?
Was ist das?
Wir haben gerade etwas gemacht.
Es ist ein Ungenas,
ein Ferrosbund,
ohne es zu wissen.
Ich finde, der Ferrosbund eigentlich nicht ist.
Okay, Herr Leipzig.
Das ist echtännerhaft.
Ich finde, dass das eine Fur-Fur-Fur ist.
Es ist eine Fur-Fur-Fur-Fur.
Wir müssen die Fur-Fur von Hypertroze vor theo.
Wir müssen die Fur-Fur-Fur von Hypertroze vor theo.
Ich denke,
dass die Fur-Fur-Fur-Fur ein Angenas ist.
Sie können es zum Beispiel Schwindelgefühl oder Globusgefühl nennen.
Ich sage es alle, es ist nicht nötig, das zu sagen.
Wenn Sie den Patienten schon gut gestaltet haben,
was bedeutet das, dass Sie ihn gut gestaltet haben?
Sie haben ihn bemerkt, Sie haben ihn bemerkt.
Das Bemerken nicht nur so sein, wie Sie ihn machen wollen.
Das Bemerken ist, dass Sie sich mit dem Bechwerden bemerken.
Sie haben sich mit dem Umkippen bemerkt, Sie haben sich mit ihm bemerkt, Sie haben seine Fragen beantwortet.
In diesen Bereichen kann man auch das sagen.
Ich habe Angst, ich habe Angst, aber Sie sind jetzt im Krankenhaus,
Sie werden uns nicht besser fühlen, Sie sind nicht mehr so gut.
Das kann man in der Anfangszeit sagen.
Und dann sagt man die restlichen Bechwerden selbst.
Man muss nicht einzig und einzig fragen.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht nötig einzig zu fragen.
Sie haben hier ein paar Beispiele gefragt.
Das hat er gesagt, das hat er gesagt und das hat er nicht gesagt.
Die Bechwerde des Andere, die Gleiszeitig Aftretten,
Sie haben ein paar Beispiele gestellt.
In der Zeit haben Sie gesagt, dass Sie das nicht gesagt haben.
Dann geht man an die Vagatetephanamnese.
In der Vagatetephanamnese fragt man viele Dinge.
Sie fragen, ob es Schweizer sind, ob man ein Interesse hat,
ob man eine Gewege oder so was fragt.
Ich habe es so verstanden, als ob ich auf die Klappe gesprungen bin.
Morgan hat die Angst, auf die Klappe zu fallen.
Die Angst, auf die Klappe zu fallen.
Er hat es vorhin zweimal getroffen.
Ja, er hat es vorhin zweimal getroffen.
Das ist wichtig.
Er hat Fragen gestellt.
Wie gesagt, wir haben Schwindel-Attak- und Müske-Skungen gefragt.
Schwindel-Attak, nicht Schwindel-Attak.
Herser-Rasen und Angst vor Umkippen.
Angst vor Umkippen.
Umkippen, dann Herser-Rasen.
In diesen Noten gibt es Schwindel-Attak.
Aber in den letzten Erfarungen hat man gesagt, dass es Schwindel-Attak nicht gibt.
Man hat gesagt, dass es Schwindel-Attak nicht gibt.
Deswegen, nicht zu viel Schwindel-Skungen.
Schwindel-Attak, umkippen.
Schwindel-Skäden.
Dann ist es, dass man hier auf die letzten Spiele Schwindel-Attak nicht in die Klappe kommt.
Man kann es nicht sagen, aber Schwindel-Attak nicht in die Klappe.
Schwindel-Rasen, Herser-Rasen und Umkippen.
Man muss sich an diese Noten konzentrieren.
Okay.
Und was hat hier schon aufgeteilt?
Nicht die andere Noten.
Schwindel-Attak.
Schwindel-Attak hat hier eine Noten aufgeteilt.
Die anderen Noten haben sie hier aufgeteilt.
Okay.
Akut gastroenteritis.
Die Spezialität dieses Falles...
Das war wohl eine Frau von Taxi-Fahrer.
Sie führten auch draußen.
Sie führten auch unvergesslich.
Sie führten so eine Verhandlung.
Was führte das?
Das war die Tramisu und Macrossion, die im Bus begangen wurde.
Sie führten sie.
Dann kamen die Widerstande.
Das Grundein ist hier die Frage des gastroenteritis.
Sie kommen mit einer Leidenschaft.
Sie fragen die Leidenschaft.
Dann fragen Sie die Stille.
Übelkeit, Erbrechen.
Sie fragen diese.
Sie haben alle Widerstande.
Sie werden sie in die Stille verbreiten.
Sie fragen die Fibre.
Sie haben alle Widerstande.
Dann kommen sie.
Die Fragen haben keine große Unterschiede.
Aber wenn Sie die Frage stellen,
können Sie die Frage stellen,
was Sie gegessen haben.
Was haben Sie gegessen?
Sie sagen, hier habe ich das und das gegessen.
Haben Sie eine komische Frage?
Haben Sie haslen oder was haben Sie gegessen?
Wie war das Al Owitz?
Haben Sie gegessen?
Ist das Essen?
Ist das Essenņ
Fardobin?
Waren dieрахразу?
Einige Hamiltonische Fragen gibt's nicht.
ob sie sich an die Schale befestigt haben, ob sie das Essen in den Kühlschrank gesetzt haben.
Dann hat Tal Dgaida Pürfagon gefragt, ob sie das Essen in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Ibrahim hat gesagt, dass er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Er hat gesagt, dass er es nicht in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat, sondern auf den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Er hat gesagt, dass er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Da hat er die Proposition, dass es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Er hat gesagt, dass er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat, aber ich weiß nicht, ob er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Deswegen sollte man nicht so viel in die Dinge gehen.
Das ist ein ganz besonderes Thema.
Die generelligen Dinge sind die Frage, ob das Essen frisch war, ob es komisch war.
Ich habe nichts bemerkt, aber es war sehr lecker, lecker, ich habe es gegessen.
Es kann auch ein bisschen zu spät sein, aber es gibt nichts, das die Patientin wissen kann.
Ob es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat, ist ein Problem.
Deswegen sollte man ein paar Dinge fragen.
Ja, es muss in die Frage kommen.
Er hat es mir gesagt, dass ich etwas fragen kann.
Er wollte es vor sich selbst zeigen, aber er hat es mir gesagt, dass er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Er hat es mir gesagt, dass er es in den Kühlschrank gesetzt hat.
Ekrem, es gibt ein bisschen in der Türkei eine Anleitung.
Sie haben es nicht verstanden, wenn man in den Kühlschrank geht.
Wir müssen die Anleitung auf die Seite nehmen.
Es kann nicht nur in die Anleitung gehen.
Die Anleitung kann sich hier nicht verändern.
Es kann sich hier nicht verändern.
Es kann sich in der Anleitung verändern.
Da war Haft da oder kommt es in Atakan?
Sürekli mir Atakan an dem gelio, wie lange da war da?
Aine Atakan gibi sordunuz.
Onda sonra Herzrazen angegefüldetig için,
tabi Akuttkornar-Syndrome hemen dışlamak lazım.
Haben Sie Bruce Schmerz und Lufnod dabei?
Diee hani sormak lazım.
Herzrazen sorguladunuz.
Bruce Schmerz in Lufnod sordunuz.
Hemen gibt es noch andere Beschwerden die Gleisheit aufgetreten.
Zum Beispiel Aine Schmerzn dedunuz.
Und dann kommt die Bauchschmerzn.
Dann sorguladet ihr die Fragen der Bauchschmerzn.
Und das ist das Gazvonetest.
Üblich, Albrechen, Schutul, Vasalas.
Und wenn es um diese Fragen geht,
dann bezeichnet ihr diese.
Hier ist es natürlich auch so,
dass die Patientin zuerst sehr leid und stresslos ist.
Dann kann man direkt etwas machen.
Herzrazen angegefüldetig.
Bruce Schmerzn, Lufnod sordunuz.
Aber es ist sehr leid.
Dann kann man direkt etwas machen.
Ich werde die Vitaminsparameter kontrollieren.
Ich werde eine Knie nehmen.
Ich werde eine AKG machen.
Um die Patientin zu entspannen.
Dann kann man es machen.
Es ist nicht so schade.
Wenn der Patient sehr leid ist.
Für alle Fälle, wenn er sehr leid ist,
dann nicht Angst machen, etwas zu machen.
Also zu machen, das bedeutet...
Normalerweise, das ist nicht so.
Wenn ihr an einem Anamnesium versucht,
dann kontrolliert ihr die Vitaminsparameter.
Der Patient schaut auf den Feuer.
Er misst die Tension.
Er bereitet die Materialien, um die Knie zu nehmen.
Das sind schon die Dinge, die Gleisheit sind.
Deswegen kann man die Patientin, die sich für die Angst hat,
in die Hände kippen.
Und dann kann man die Vitaminsparameter kontrollieren.
Das ist es.
Hier die letzte Frage.
Ferlach Diagnose Reiss-Magen-Gendrome.
Reiss-Darm-Sendrome.
Du nennst das Reiss-Darm-Sendrome?
Ja, das ist das Reiss-Darm-Sendrome.
Reiss-Darm-Sendrome.
Sollten wir das der Patient so sagen?
Oder Reiss-Magen-Darm-Emping-Gleit?
Oder ich muss es in einer anderen Weise sagen?
Ich nenne das Reiss-Magen-Darm-Emping-Gleit.
Reiss-Magen-Darm-Emping-Gleit.
Das kann man auch in der Sprache benutzen.
Ich habe es schon mal gemacht.
Reiss-Darm-Sendrome.
Die differential diagnostic gastroesophageal reflux und akut karnonarm syndrome.
Das kann man so nennen, aber ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Weil ich in Reiss-Magen-Darm-Sendrome bin und in der Sprache bin.
Weil es nach dem Essen ausgelöst ist, wollte ich gastroentheritis und Ulcus ventriculis oder akut pankratis.
Aber bei der differential diagnostic hast du keine Angst.
Seht nur zwei.
Wer sich als Ort an sich erinnert, ist der Papa Afshin-Mersun.
Er kann alles an sich erinnern.
Er kann auch der gastroentheritis und Ulcus ventriculis an sich erinnern.
Er kann auch akut karnonarm syndrome an sich erinnern.
Er kann auch pankratis an sich erinnern.
Er kann auch cholestitis an sich erinnern.
Er kann auch gastroentheritis an sich erinnern.
Da hat man keine Angst.
Warum habe ich es gesagt?
Weil es der Papa Afshin-Mersun ist.
Deswegen habe ich diese differential diagnose gedacht.
Weil es der Papa Afshin-Mersun ist, habe ich das gedacht.
Dann bin ich da.
Dann habe ich die eine Erwünschung von Chemotherapie.
Das ist die Nebenwirkung von Chemotherapie.
Das ist die Erwünschung von Chemotherapie.
Ich glaube, dass die Menschen sich nicht gut fühlen.
Vielleicht haben sie sich schmerzen oder schlafen sie nicht gut.
Man zeigt Empathie.
Linguinal, inguinal bölgede bir aarım var, ordan aareyi sorgulamaya başlıyorsunuz,
Auslöseyi sorunca Lymph, Clotin, and Fernung, ordan Malinx melanoma giriyo, ne zamandır bu var,
o aarın arasında bunları öğreniyorsunuz, sonra aareyi tamamlıyorsunuz,
ordan sonra, mesela bu chemotherapy vakasina başka bir sürü şikayeti var,
yan etkiyi oldu için chemotherapyni,
aber siz bunları tek tek sorgulamak zorunda değilsiniz,
aareyi sorguladınız, aareyi sorgularken chemotherapy meselelerini öğrendiniz, malinx melanoma,
bunların herberini öğreniyorsunuz, ona sordukça çıkan şeylerle baal olarak sordunuz sorularda,
sonra gibt es noch andere Bechwerden, die Gleisheit, die Aufgetreten,
o kendisi bir kaç semptom söylüyo,
söylemese bile, vegetative anamnese sırasında,
Hani, bir sürü şey soruyosunuz, Fiba'yi soruyosunuz, işte kalp ve lung'in yan etkileri chemotherapy'in açısından,
işte Leiden's Junta, Bruce Schmerzen, Nufnod, NGG Füelo, da Herzrazen, hani bunu sorgulamış oluyosunuz,
ondan sonra gastrointestinal system yan etkileriçin, Aschduelgang, Wassalas'ın probleme,
Übülde, Kajde, Erbre, f.a. hani bunların herberini sorgulamış oluyosunuz,
vegetative anamnese dede, o yüzden çok böyle endişelenmenize gerek yok.
Bir de siz sormayı unuttunuz, işte diyelim ki, Aschda da söylemedi, bu citti bi sorun değil yani.
Hani sonuçte chemotherapy'nin tonlarca yan etkisi olabilir, sınırsız yan etkisi olabilir,
yani biz onların herberinde sorgulayamayız.
Bunun şey konusunda, Firaud Danisch'in bi şeyi vardı, Tanr konusunda itirazi vardı hocam,
ne diyordu, hani bu şeyimizin un ervuncete arsenal mittel becogdea schemotherapie.
Bunu İbrahim Osman hoca da bu vakadan yapmıştı ya, hani bu Tanı yazdığı için,
işte onun prüferi, hani onu biraz eleştirmişti, bu değil yani Tanı gibi diye.
Sanki işte Pansitopenia orada duymak istetiklerini hani söylemiş,
o zaman Pansitopenia unta chemotherapy gibi bir şey yazmasını istemiş diye.
Hani orada Tanı'yi öyle yazabilirsiniz, Pansitopenia unta chemotherapy gibi yazılabilir.
Tabi ben onu bilmiyordum, tabi o zamanlar ben böyle yazarım diye.
Hastajen nebel virkungen von chemotherapy diyordum,
Firdah Diagnose, hemdokumentation, hemdifade edeceğim zaman, un ervuncete ars ein mittel von chemotherapy şekilde diyordum.
Aber yani öyle yazmasanız da ciddi bir sorun olmuyor.
Hatta bazen bu kazanc olabiliyor, sen karşı gelmiosun prüfere,
neden bunun böyle olduğunu anlatıyor biraz,
onun konuşması, onun anlatması da bir zaman kazanmaz olabol.
Das ist ein bisschen niedergeflogenes Information.
Das ist ein bisschen niedergeflogenes.
Aber hastaja söylerken, bunu şey diye söylüyoruz, auf neben virkungen der Chemotherapie olabildiyince basit.
Aynen, aynen.
Neben virkungen der Chemotherapie.
Nur da kalırsakta gerçek anamnize bile bunu yapustrabiliriz.
Aynen, aynen.
In der Paranteise gibt es auch Pansütopen.
Warum?
Einem ist eine Geheimdurchsicht, einem ist eine Infektion, einem ist eine Blutdauer.
Einem ist ein Symptom, das an den allgemeinen Blutdauer der Blutdauer bemerkt.
Achtung, Achtung.
Was ist das, was ich jetzt erzählen soll?
Heisfirber-Zolle-Syndrom.
Hier.
Das ist auch ein klassischer Schmerz.
Aber weil es mit Kopfschmerzen und Nackenschmerzen kommt,
Die Fragen, die du wählst, sind wichtig.
Die Frage, wo die Schmerzen sind,
die Frage, die du wählst,
die Gruppe, die du wählst, ist wichtig.
Du machst hier den klassischen Schmerz-Fragen.
Dann, weil es der Kopfschmerz ist,
du fragst Fragen über Neurologie.
Das war ein junger Patient.
Da er jung war,
wie er sich hier aus dem Kopf schmerzt,
ist das nicht wichtig.
Deswegen ist es nicht nötig,
um hier zu fragen,
wie er sich hier aus dem Kopf schmerzt.
Dann die Neurologie-Fragen.
Leiden Sie unter der Tase-Störung,
der Hörstörung oder der Sprachstörung?
Hier, um Apoplexie zu entnehmen,
um Tia zu entnehmen,
fragt man diese Fragen.
Dann gibt es einen Kopfschmerz.
Du kannst auch fragen,
ob es mit Migräne-Fragen oder mit Laut-Fragen ist.
Ich habe diese Fragen auch in der Neurologie.
Schwindel, Bebewusstein, Ferdor, Rön,
dann Lehmung, Erscheinung, Kribel,
dann Schleif, Erscheinung, Schleif,
dann Zähstörung, Hörstörung, Sprachstörung,
dann Lichtenfinden, Lärmenfinden.
Das waren die Neurologie-Fragen.
Dann gibt es die Vagatätifanamnese.
Dann geht es um diese Fragen und endet es.
Was ist im Spezifischen der Krankheit?
Wenn man die Auslöse fragt,
ist es wichtig, die Auslöse
spezifisch im Spezifischen der Krankheit zu vermitteln.
Wenn man den Schmerzschmerzen auf den Kopf hat,
kann man die die ganze Zeit beherrschen.
Man kann dafür einen Schmerzschmerz sagen.
Oder man kann einen auch sagen.
Oder man kann eine schweren Zeit,
die Gewalt, die Schmerzen,
auf die Auslöse fragen.
Wenn Sie die soziale Anamnesie in den Augen nehmen, fragen Sie.
Wenn Sie nicht genug Zeit haben, um alle zu fragen,
nehmen Sie die soziale Anamnesie etwas vor.
Wenn Sie Nikotinkondüme oder Allergien haben,
fragen Sie vor.
Sie müssen nicht die Züge abwenden.
Die Grundlage ist, dass dieser Patient wegen seiner Arbeit diese Probleme hat.
Sie haben hier zwei Anmerkungen gemacht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Befragung des Präsidents auf HUB-5-Ver. machen.
Wenn er das beantwortet, dann ist das das Problem.
Okay.
Und zweitens, hier, als Sie die Anwesenden beantwortet haben,
haben wir in der letzten Sitzung nichts gesagt.
Muskelferschpanung im Nackenberach.
Ja, ich sagte so.
Heißwirbel-Zolle-Syndrom funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe es gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo die Anwesenden hergehen.
Wenn das so ist, dann können die Anwesenden ein hohes Schock vornehmen.
Das ist das, was ich gesagt habe.
Muskelferschpanung im Nackenberach.
Das ist die gleiche Sache für Discus Prolapse.
Das ist auch für Sie ein Problem.
Das ist so, wie ich es in den beiden Sitzungen sagen werde.
Das ist für die Anwesenden ein Problem.
Das ist für Sie ein positiver Punkt.
Es ist nicht einfach, eine Fahbegriffik zu benutzen.
Das ist für die Anwesenden ein Problem.
Das ist wichtig für die Menschen.
Wollen Sie eine ergonomische Position?
Haben Sie das schon gesagt?
Rücken gerade halten, Schultan entspannen, beide Füße auf dem Boden.
In den Runden, da sie das auch gefragt haben, habe ich das nicht gesagt.
Aber wenn sie das auch fragen, habe ich die Not gelesen und das gelesen.
Wie man da stehen muss.
Muskelferschpanung im Nackenberach.
Das ist ein sehr starkes Stab.
Das ist das, was ich hier gesagt habe.
Und das ist in den letzten Monaten so, wie es in den letzten Monaten war.
Aber es ist leichter, als es in den letzten Monaten war.
Das ist so.
Ich habe es mir sehr gefallen.
Ich habe es mit dem Fall von Ibrahim gesagt.
Ibrahim ist hier in der Kardiologik.
Das ist wie Akut-Koronar-Syndrom.
Das ist wie der Herz-Gefäß.
Hier gibt es auch die Darm-Gefäß.
Zuerst ist Angina Bauch.
Das ist ein Monat lang wieder so.
Es ist dann leichter.
Aber jetzt ist es ein Infarkt.
Das ist ein Darminfarkt.
Genau wie der Herzinfarkt.
In diesem Fall ist es so.
Es ist ein sehr starkes Stab.
Das ist ein Infarkt.
Das ist ein sehr starkes Stab.
In einem Monat gibt es solche Schikäden.
Das ist so.
Deswegen ist die Frage der Schmerzen sehr wichtig.
Ist das das erste Mal?
Oder war es das erste Mal?
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Das muss man in den Fällen nicht vergessen.
In den Fällen gibt es keine Schikäden.
Das ist das, was wichtig ist.
In diesem Fall ist die Schmerzen sehr stark.
In allen Schmerzen, die es gibt,
wenn es über die 7 oder 8 Schmerzen gibt,
müssen wir uns empathisch an die Schmerzen bewegen.
Das ist ein Schmerz.
Wenn sie nach dem Besuch gehen, kann sie die Schmerzmittel nicht mehr versorgen.
Sie können sie nicht mehr versorgen, wenn sie nicht mehr versorgen.
Sie können die Schmerzmittel nicht mehr versorgen.
Dann nach dem Besuch.
Sie müssen sich selbst entschuldigen.
Ja, Herr Tutor.
Wenn du den Patienten das Wort nennst, ist das ein Blutgefäß.
Ja, das kannst du auch nennen.
Ich habe es so gesagt.
Du hast einen Blutgefäß.
Du hast einen Blutgefäß im Blut.
Die Pferdediagnose des akutes Abdommens im Rahmen eines mesenterellen Impakts.
Akutes Abdommens im Rahmen eines mesenterellen Impakts.
Aber wenn wir das nur als mesenterellen Impakts in der Brief schreiben,
wird es für uns ein Problem sein?
Was ist ein Problem?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber das Wichtigste hier ist, dass es ein akutes Abdomen ist.
Aber das Akutes Abdomen ist kein Abdomen.
Das ist ein Symptom, ein Kürbnis und ein Ergebnis eines Akutes.
Und das ist ein akutes Abdomen.
Ich denke, dass das im Basis des Mesenterellen Impakts passiert.
Das ist wie das Pancreatitis.
Das ist wie das Chronische Pancreatitis.
und auch der anderen Tatsache, den ihr erwähnen könnt,
kann Akute-Aptomen mit dem Begriffe Akute-Pancreatitis sein.
Ich habe das so genannt.
Ich habe das an Akute-Apandesi-Taske genannt.
Aber das kann mit dem Akute-Aptomen mit dem Begriffe Akute-Aptomen sein.
Ich habe es so genannt.
Wie kommt es auf euch an?
Ich habe das Akute-Schub Chroniche-Pancreatitis.
Aber in diesem Fall kann man auch schon in chronischem Pancreatitis spielen.
Die Dinge, die er als Berufsfrau sagt, sind manchmal etwas, die wir nicht oft in der daglichen Lebenswahl hören.
Das kann seltsam werden und die Menschen können es nicht verstehen.
Wenn man es nicht versteht, ist es nicht schön, wenn man es nicht versteht.
Dieser Fall spielt in verschiedenen Formen.
Ich nenne es die Papazen, die in der deutschen Sprache, die Alaina Musikale sind, aber sie haben einen anderen Namen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie auf meinen Noten sind oder ob sie auf sie sind.
Es ist gut, sie zu wissen, sie zu hören.
War das der Papaz Pfeife?
Para.
Was?
Para, Herr.
Para.
So ist es.
Es gibt nichts anderes.
Es ist akut und pankratisch, aber es ist auch stöterisch.
Alaina Unta Haltai.
Sie spielt und singt in den Musikbarn.
Papaz in der Pfaffe.
Sie hat die Schweige, dass sie nicht in der Stöte eine Art Sturzdiagnose hat.
Aber sie spielt so.
Ist es etwas mit der Akut-Pankratis?
Etwas mit der Akut-Pankratis, Herr.
Wir werden die Stöte anhand der Anamnesen anbieten.
Akut und Schub, eine chronischen Pankratitis.
Nein, Akut und Pankratis.
Wir werden die Akut-Pankratis nennen.
Wir nennen sie die Pankratis, wenn sie uns eine Anmeldung anbieten.
Bauchschpa Heldurus ensunduk.
Bauchschpa Heldurus ensunduk, Herr.
Ich nenne sie die Coludoco Littiasis.
Sie nennen sie die Schole Littiasis.
Hier ist es die Oba Bauchmersen.
Rehte Zayde Oba Bauchmersen.
Hier ist es die Aare-Anamnese.
Das ist die Aare-Anamnese, die mit Öl am Essen beginnt.
Das ist wichtig.
Die grundlegende Faktor, die hier darin steht, ist die Hele.
Die Duncla-Materialien.
Sie zeigen, dass sie ein Schütz sind.
Sie können euch bei der Coludoco Littiasis helfen.
Wenn ihr diese hört, könnt ihr sie sich vorstellen.
Ist da noch etwas Besonderes?
Ich erinnere mich nicht an etwas sehr Besonderes.
Das ist es.
Die Grundlage ist die Oba Bauchmersen.
Rehte Zayde Oba Bauchmersen.
Hele Schütz und Duncla-Materialien.
Das kann man auch als Coludoco Littiasis nennen.
Sie nennen es die Coludoco Littiasis.
Das ist es.
Wenn man den Patienten eine Anzeige macht,
kann man sagen, dass es genug ist.
Ja, das ist es.
Wenn man die Babyküste anzeigt,
kann man sagen, dass es genug ist.
Ja, das ist es.
Okay, gut.
Was hast du mit der Ferda-Diagnose gedacht?
Die Reaktionen sind wichtig.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an die Schmerzen.
Aber wenn es ein Schmerz ist,
dann erinnern wir uns nicht an die Schmerzen.
Ja, das hat sich unterschiedlich gemacht.
Gut, was ist es?
Uncontrollable Diabetes Mellitus und Arterielehypertone.
Hier kommt der Patient zu Koppschmerzen.
Deswegen wird man in diesem Sinne die Kopfhörer ein bisschen verabschieden.
Es ist etwas zu spät, was in diesem Fall passiert.
Aber wenn es ein Koppschmerzen-Kommand ist,
dann gibt es nicht so viele Kommanden.
Da kann man sich über die Diabetes Mellitus denken.
Aber wie können wir das verstanden haben?
Wenn es ein Foyer-Krank-Anamnese ist,
dann sagt man, dass es ein Diabetes Mellitus und Arterielehypertone ist.
Das kritische Punkt ist hier.
Wie ist der Zika,
wie ist er kontrolliert?
Was ist das, was er in der letzten Zeit kontrolliert hat?
Es ist wichtig, das zu fragen.
Um die Anamnese zu beherrschen.
Dann wird der Patient in der Kompassierung
und in der Kompassierung in der Kompassierung
ein paar Neurologen selbst fragen.
Wie es bei der Funktion des Halswirbels
und dem Syndrome ist.
Wie ist der Schwindel?
Wie ist der Schombeibus?
Wie ist der Lamenerscheinungen?
Wie ist das Kribasgefühl?
Das ist ein kontrolliertes Diabetes-Mellitus.
Und kontrolliertes Arterielehypertone.
Arterielehypertone.
Ich habe die beiden geschrieben.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass man die beiden zusammen schreiben kann.
Generell ist es ein Polydipsis und Polyurin.
Stabbeksul und Gleisung
by ein kontrolliertes Diabetes-Mellitus.
Das ist ein Differenzialdiagnose.
Was ist die nächste Frage?
Akute Piole Nephritis.
Das ist eine Art Akute Piole Nephritis.
Das sind die Fakten, die in der Äußerung sind.
Das ist die Erkundung von Akute Piole Nephritis.
Wenn sie die Antibiotik beobachten,
dann gehen sie direkt in die Piole Nephritis.
Ja, wenn man die Antibiotik-Erkunde besagt.
Hier ist es wichtig, das zu klaren.
Wenn man die Anamnesen der Patient macht.
Wenn man die Antibiotik bekommt, sagt man,
dass sie die Patientin nicht mehr beobachten.
Dann ist die Patientin die Erkunde der Patientin.
Wenn ich das vorher hatte,
dann musste ich die Anamnesen mehr beobachten.
Von diesem Grund habe ich sie eher zu Hause gegründet.
Um sie zu nutzen.
Hier sind die Anamnesen der Patienten arabisch vertreten.
Wenn sie diese die Anamnesen nicht mehr beobachten,
dann könnten sie die Anamnesen nicht mehr beobachten.
Das kann die Anamnesen mit der Diebenung von Ärztlichen,
Anamnesen mit der Diebenung von Erkunden nicht mehr beobachten.
Das ist sehr müde.
Das kommt mit dieser Begegnung.
Nur wenn sie müde ist, wie ich es gesagt habe,
wie es in der Chemotherapie passiert ist,
kann man in die Begegnung sagen,
dass sie sich müde fühlen, vielleicht haben sie Schmerzen oder haben sie Schlafstörungen.
Aber sie kommt immer mit müde.
Sie kann direkt ihre Begegnungen sagen.
Die Begegnung ist eine Begegnung, die die Schmerzen und die Schlafstörungen verursacht.
Sie ist müde.
Sie hat sich gefragt, ob sie Schmerzen oder Schlafstörungen haben.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie zwei Schmerzen haben.
Dann fragt man diese.
Schmerzen hat eine typische Schmerzen-Fähigkeit.
Morgan hat eine Schmerzen-Fähigkeit.
Die Schmerzen der Schlafstörungen sind ein paar Stunden später.
Dann geht es weiter.
Daher muss man nicht alle Fragen über Schmerzen fragen.
Man kann nur die Schmerzen von Morgan,
Schmerzen von Sytwan,
Schmerzen von Fershwin,
Schmerzen, die nachher aufgewacht sind,
ob sie verschwinden,
die Schmerzen.
Dann kann man die Charakter, die Schmerzen fragen.
Dann kann es losgehen.
Dann kann man die Schmerzen fragen.
In welcher Schlafstörung haben Sie kicking?
In welcher Schlafstörung haben Sie KNP?
Sie kann die Schlafstörungen fragen.
Er sagt, dass er mit seiner Frau ein bisschen zusammenkommt, weil er seine Frau aus dem Hörer liest,
und er sagt, dass seine Frau mit dem Hörer aus dem Hörer liest.
Aber ich habe in ein paar Erfarben gehört, dass jeder mit dem Hörer mit dem Hörer liest.
Wenn er nicht liest, ist das kein Problem.
Und hier spricht er etwas umgangssprachlich.
Also, er nutzt verschiedene Wörter, wie schnarchen und atme auszusetzen.
Was war das?
Koyschen.
Und dann...
Wirken.
Ja, das ist ein Vigge-Schein.
Das bedeutet etwas um Atme auszusetzen.
Denn es ist so, dass man plötzlich nicht atmen kann, und dann beginnt man zu atmen.
Hier ist der Atme auszusetzen.
Koyschen ist eine Art Stimme, die sich mit dem Atmen auszusetzen.
Das bedeutet schnarchen.
Da ist es wichtig zu denken.
Diese zwei Wörter sind wichtig.
Der Patient bezeichnet sie so.
Und auch, dass es ein Angriff auf ein Atmen ist.
Ein Angriff.
Ein Angriff, Koyschen.
Was war das dritte?
Was war das, Chetin?
Das war ein Wirken.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Anikon, Koyschen, Mevchosh.
Das war ein Wirken.
Ja, ein Wirken.
Was bedeutet das?
Das ist ein kacke Stimme, das man im Atmen auszusetzen kann.
Das Atmen.
Das ist ein anderes Stimme.
Das ist ein Hürdchen.
Das ist ein Hürdchen, das man im Atmen auszusetzen kann.
Oder das ist ein Atmen, das man im Atmen auszusetzen kann.
Das ist ein Atmen, das man im Atmen auszusetzen kann.
Ich habe diese Wörter mit etwas zusammengelegt.
Das Wirken.
Das Atmen auszusetzen, das Koyschen mit Schnarchen.
Wenn ich das höre, dann ist das ein Schnarchen.
Das Atmen auszusetzen.
So.
Das ist ein Schnaufbezogener Atemsturung.
Ja, das ist ein Schnaufbezogener Atemsturung.
Das kann man so nennen.
Dann gibt es auch Diskusprolapsus.
Diskusprolapsus erhört die Floreste, die Aarzache.
Wenn man einen Atemsturzbruch fragt, ist die Situation vorhanden.
Ich habe eine Kubel gelegt, es ist eine Aarzüge.
Dann fragt man eine Aarzüge.
Wenn die Aarzüge fertig sind,
fragt man einen Atemsturzbruch.
Hier ist vielleicht das Schnaufbezogener Atemsturzbruch wichtig.
Da gibt es keine anderen Fragen.
Ja, Herr.
Aber in der Medikament-Kassemangehörigkeit,
was ist das?
Was ist das?
Wo ist das?
Das kann man fragen.
Ich habe es nicht gelesen, aber der Kind
hat es ihm vorgesprochen,
um sich gegen Osteoporose zu schützen.
Oder wenn er das ist,
dann kann er sagen,
dass er das ist,
dass es sein muss,
wenn er das ist.
Das kann man auch fragen.
Auch für die Sachen,
die man in der Medikament-Kassemangehörigkeit
bezeichnen kann.
Das kann man fragen.
Ja, Herr.
Was wir gesagt haben,
das ist etwas schwierig für mich,
das zu sagen.
Das muss man nicht so lange sagen.
Das ist es.
Da muss man nicht so lange sagen.
Das kann man auch versuchen.
Da kann man auch versuchen...
Oder so.
Also oder so.
Aber da hat man einer Давайßigkeit,
um Daniel anzufassen,
dass man das nicht so krass spending소리ert.
Ratig!
Richtig!
Das hat man auch nicht so matters tradicionalm nach der Medikament-Kasse.
Dann ist es gut, eine Reaktion zu machen.
Ich habe auch eine andere Akute-Apandisitis-Fakade.
Akute-Apandisitis ist keine besondere Sache.
Das Grundein ist die Schmerzen-Küste.
Wenn du die Schmerzen von Anfang an in der Rechten Unten Bauch hast,
dann wirst du die Schmerzen von anderen Orten in der Rechten Unten Bauch verbreiten.
Das ist die klassische Frage der Akute-Apandisitis.
Sondern du bekommst eine Aar-Anamnesen.
Du hast ein Gas-Düfen-System.
Du hast die klassischen Fragen von Übel-Kaide, Erbrah-Hön, Stürgank, Wasalas.
Du hast die Schmerzen von Frauen.
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen von Frauen.
Die Leute wissen das nicht.
Aber im Umgangssprachlichen wird diese Diagnose genannt.
Die werden die Diagnose genannt.
Deswegen sagen wir das.
Die Differenz der Diagnose ist die Hypertensie und z.B. Morbus Crohn.
Durch diese Differenz im Umgang der Schmerzen wird die Hypertensie gelöst.
Hüsten ist trocken oder etwas auswürflich.
Das ist wohl nicht auswürflich, aber es gibt auswürfliche, die auswirfen.
Die Grundsatznummer ist Hüsten.
Sie fragen diese Menschen.
Wenn es diese Menschen gibt,
dann stellt man diese Menschen den Besuch aus.
Sie fragen sich, wie viele Szenen sie haben.
Wenn es gibt, dann fragt man sich selbst.
Aber das ist in der Art der Atak Artige,
da Lufnot und Herzrasen zusammen sind.
Darüber kannst du ein paar spezielle Fragen stellen.
Also, wie viele Szenen sie haben,
wie viele sie haben,
ob es in den Nachts oder morgens,
in den ersten Stunden,
wenn es um die Zeit geht,
wie viele sie haben,
diese Fragen kannst du fragen.
Wenn du sie nicht zu Beginn gesagt hast,
und sie diese Fragen zufällig gefunden haben,
dann ist es nicht nötig, sie zu fragen.
Die Patientin hat sehr schnell eine Reaktion.
Sie sagt immer, dass sie nicht zufällig fragt.
Wie können wir da einfach in die Zeit gehen?
Oder wir machen so ein Stopp?
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ich habe es gesagt, um das zu erklären,
und um Zeit zu holen.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ich habe das gesagt.
Das möchte ich獻e nicht газen.
Das wollte ich nicht.
Wenn ich etwas anderes sagen würde und ich es nicht verstehe, würde ich sagen, dass ich das nicht mehr verstanden habe.
Ich habe mir die Frage gestellt, ob ich etwas mehr fragen muss.
Ich habe die Frage gestellt, ob ich etwas mehr fragen muss.
Ok, danke. Was ist in der Zeit?
Wenn ich die Frage an einen Patienten anschaue, ob er aus Auslöse ist, hat er keine Antwort.
Ich habe immer mit L-Formul so gelesen.
Wenn ich die Frage an die Allergie-Kasse habe, hat er gesagt, dass er in der Kindheit von Katzenhare allergisch war.
Dann habe ich die Frage gestellt, ob ich in der Zeit Kontakt mit einem Katzen oder anderen Tieren hatte.
Da habe ich die Frage gestellt, ob ich in der Zeit Kontakt mit einem Katzen oder anderen Tieren hatte.
Dann habe ich die Frage gestellt, ob es zwischen einem Bescheid und einem Befehl eine Beziehung gibt.
Es gibt Lufnot, Hüsten, Fibers, Bruce Shimmerson, Heismerson.
Es gibt Heismerson, da muss man nicht so viel aufnehmen.
Es gibt Bruce Shimmerson, da kann man nicht so viel aufnehmen, wie bei einem Coronersendron.
Es gibt auch Lufnot und Hüsten, da kann man nicht so viel aufnehmen.
Es gibt auch Lungenembolie und Pneumothorax.
Das kann man bei den anderen Tieren sehen.
Aber normalerweise gibt es eine Schikade seit drei Wochen und eine seit sechs Tagen.
Daher kommt mir nicht viel auf.
Aber wenn man sich die Auslöse fragt, kann man sich die Frage stellen, ob sie Bruce Shimmerson oder Pneumothorax haben.
Dann kann man sich die Frage stellen, ob sie Lungenembolie haben.
In der Auslöse-Auslöse-Auslöse gibt es auch eine Schikade, die sich in der Auslöse-Auslöse befindet.
Die Auslöse-Auslöse hat eine Schikade, die sich in der Auslöse befindet.
Ich habe auch eine Schikade, dass ich eine Pneumothorax-Differenzia-Diagnose durch die Viral-Pneumothorax-Auslöse durchgeführt habe.
Daher habe ich mir die Frage gestellt, ob ich eine Schikade habe, ob ich eine Hüsten-Auslöse habe oder eine Lufnot habe.
Ich habe auch die Frage gestellt, ob ich eine Schmerz-Test-Auslöse habe.
Warum fragst du diese Fragen?
Um den COVID-Nose zu verbreiten.
Es bedeutet nicht, dass man den COVID-Nose nicht verbreitet, aber es ist eine Frage, die das beinhaltet.
Würdest du dir eine Reaktion geben, wenn du diese Patientin auf die Diät verbreitet?
Ich würde.
Wer hat es Ihnen empfohlen?
Ich habe es mir einfach gesagt, dass ich es auf der Internet gefunden habe.
Aber ich habe gesagt, dass ich verstehe, dass Sie Gewicht abnehmen möchten.
Aber unser Körper braucht viel Energie.
Deswegen kann ich Ihnen gerne eine Diätassistentin empfehlen.
Professionell empfehlen, das müssen Sie.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass Sie ein Schiff haben.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, wie Sie ein Name oder eine andere Name aufgeben.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, warum Sie das Name aufgeben, warum Sie das aufgeben.
Es ist nicht so wichtig, ob das richtig ist oder nicht.
Ich habe die Mesentereinigung gesagt, weil es eine Schmerzenkrise gibt.
Es ist eine Schmerzenkrise, die Schmerzen sehr stark sind.
Aber ist es etwas, das den Schmerzen verursacht?
Nein, das ist es nicht.
Ich habe es mir gesagt, ich habe es mir gesagt.
Es geht ums Gespräch.
Was soll das für ein Patient sagen?
Darmen-Zundung.
Darmen-Zundung ist ein bisschen zu viel.
Differential Diagnostics, Colon Carcinoma und Reisdarm Syndrome.
Reisdarm Syndrome ist nicht so gut für diese Patientin.
Darum sollte man nicht Reisdarm Syndrome sagen.
Es ist das erste Mal, dass sie Stress und so weiter nicht vermittelt.
Es ist nicht anders als ein anderes Verkauf.
Dann kann ich es mal versuchen.
Du kannst es als andere sagen.